Another type of photo immune therapy, infrared light, also injects to the site of the tumor.
Yeah, that's a type of what's called photo biomodulation.
So a photo biomodulation is using laser slash infrared slash a light therapy of some kind.
You're even getting photo biomodulation when you're doing right.
But photo biomodulation really got its name from using not infrared but using laser.
And then using a chemical or you could do photo biomodulation with any chemical any chemical that's going to be attracted to kill the cancer directly.
There's a lot of natural things that do that.
One photo biomodulator thing you could do at home is using methylene blue.
And I before you go to bed with your right machine, you could use methylene blue with an infrared sauna or using it with red light therapy.
I did put a video on methylene blue on the member site on the homepage of the member site.
If you want to watch that, that can be an agent as well.
But I know photo biomodulation is done at some clinics as well.
Yeah, and the photo biomodulation type therapies do not injure healthy cells at all.
The argument is how much it's doing to the cancer cell is debatable.
Again, you get some rogue university that wants to get funded because you got some naturally alternative believing scientists that they may get one source of funding to get something published and then it gets thrown under the rug and tripled on by standards of care.
Unfortunately, even most of the large colleges that are doing cancer research are only getting funding to do studies that have to do with their pharmaceuticals.
I used to have a staff person that worked with her husband was a brilliant scientist he was a cancer researcher at the University of Minnesota for decades.
He totally 100% believed in what we do.
He said, he said, Kevin, I asked my boss once, you know, how come we're not working harder to find a cure for cancer because he was a cancer researcher.
He says, we're not trying to find a cure for cancer. We're just getting you're just here to get your next our next grant.
Well, unfortunately, he was very honest and that's a very sad truth of where we're at in this country is that everybody's just looking to get their next grant they don't really care about outcomes.